so when I was 18 years old
two weeks after I turned 18 I sat for
and passed my affiliate real estate
brokers license two years later which is
a two-year waiting requirement in the
state of Tennessee where I lived and
still live I've set forward past my
brokers so I've been a real estate
broker an affiliate broker since 1978 a
broker since 1980
still active license in the state of
Tennessee I believe in the real estate
business now I will tell you I grew up
in the business I know the business
inside now I know the type of people
that work in the business I'm not up to
snuff on all the technologies in every
little detail these days there's a lot
of uses of the web that weren't there
when I actually sold houses a million
years ago
of course we interact with some 2,000
Realtors across and real estate agents
across America and I'll tell you this
the Pareto principle works in the real
estate business just like it works in
most things 80% of the people make 20%
of the money 20% of the people make 80%
of money so if you're going to sell your
most expensive asset in most homes in
most most households your most expensive
thing that you own is your home if
you're going to hire someone to help you
market that a professional marketer get
the best get someone that sells a ton of
houses you know 80 90 200 houses a year
get somebody that you know they sold
three houses last year what crap you're
almost as good as they are why would you
hire them and pay them 6% all right
seven percent or whatever it is in your
area that's absolutely silly but when
get a stellar top-line high quality
realtor that adds value to the
transaction all the studies tell us that
you will end up making more and/or
saving more than they cost you and
here's the deal see in a typical real
estate transaction there's two sides to
the commission the person who brings the
buyer usually gets half of the
Commission the person who has the house
listed the seller at selling agent
usually gets half the Commission and so
if you want to list the house yourself
meaning a Fizbo for sale by owner you
put the sign in the yard if a real
estate agent brings you a buyer they're
going to expect to be paid 3% and you're
probably going to want to pay them 3%
get the house sold so really you're not
saving the whole commission you're
saving half the Commission and if an
individual walks up to buy your house
you know why they're going to knock on
your door if you've got a for sale by
owner sign it's not because your house
is so dadgum cute it's because they
think they're going to get a better deal
because you're saving the commission
well you and that buyer can't both save
the same commission and so you end up
negotiating away on average part of that
Commission you don't get full retail in
that kind of a setting typically so I
don't endorse real estate agents as LPS
so that I can get a commission I do get
a commission I get a referral fee when
you use one of our endorsed local
providers for real estate and that's
disclosed it's perfectly legal I'm a
broker it's fine but I don't do it for
that reason I do it I recommend you use
a high-quality high-dollar realtor that
knows their stuff it is you know high
protein high octane I recommend you use
them because it's best for you you on
average will net more using that
high-octane high production realtor real
estate agent then you will try to sell
the thing on your own
some kind of little system and you know
you get your cute little sign and you
pay a little fee here or there it just
doesn't work guys but studies are all
out there it's very simple so that's why
I recommend and we strongly recommend if
you go list your house do it if you're
going to look for a house you're going
to have a lot better experience looking
for and purchasing a home through a real
good real estate agent then you are just
out there wandering around hoping you
stumble into something you can end up
overpaying for something you don't know
what the values are you know the same
thing goes true when you get ready list
your house you could list it for too
little and then it you know you get you
left money on the table because you
don't know the values well you you don't
know about you just don't not like
someone who's got access to all the
equipment and all the web data ought to
really dig in and find out what's going
on so don't fool yourself you're not
fooling anybody with this don't do that
so my advice use a good realtor hey guys
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video click the subscribe button to get
the latest content and check out these
other great clips from the show so you
have to break the cycle you have to flip
this thing on its head and make it
behave you've got to get so fired up and
wired up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you